well I'm it I think writers no matter
where you how many places you might
settle in life you're always only from
one place and for me that's you know
working class outer-borough immigrant I
grew up in a housing project so I you
know that tends to be home for me when
it went something sort of piques my
interest and makes me want to write I
always tend to be gravitating back
towards that no matter what and I don't
really challenge it anymore just go with
it I don't like you know I'm not gonna
write about you know the Spanish Armada
just to show people a versatile I mean
you know if that's where something's
telling me to go I just go and I do the
best job I can and hopefully every time
out I'm writing a little more nuanced
and about a different facet of life but
you know a place is just the place you
know it's what you're it's all about the
human nature don't think anybody ever
writes about is trouble you know you can
find plenty of trouble but on by the
same token look if if if I grew up in
the Midwest I'd probably be writing
about you know farms you know and and
Midwestern life out southern ER you know
I'd be trying to write like some time
you know third-rate William Faulkner if
I was from the desert I'd write like
Cormac McCarthy you know you you go back
you hear it calling to your whole life
no matter where you are